[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on croit fort de la liste c'est une
liste déjà nous avons une partie de la
liste 1 nous sommes déjà en place dont
une expérience je vous le disais à
l'instant en ce qui me concerne une
expérience d'un mandat de maire adjoint
aux écoles et j'ai pour habitude de dire
que l'école est une bonne école pour
savoir aborder de manière très
transversal tous les problèmes d'une
d'une collectivité
et puis sur la liste que j'ai pas mal
renouvelée des nouvelles personnes avec
une grande diversité parce que j'ai
souhaité que cette liste soit sans
étiquette politique
c'est un choix que j'ai fait mon point
fort du programme c'est bah écoutez
c'était avant cette crise sanitaire
c'est la solidarité
une volonté vraiment de remettre à coup
au coeur de notre façon travail et la
solidarité qui a déjà un énorme réseau
sur la ville de rambouillet on a vu
durant la crise à quel point ça a été
important mais continuer à apporter ça
la solidarité la convivialité
[Applaudissements]
alors la première décision ce sera déjà
de travailler à un retour à la vie la
plus normale possible après cette crise
sanitaire
ça va donc être envers les familles pour
qu'elles trouvent l'accueil pour leurs
enfants durant les vacances
et puis ça va être aussi accompagner le
retour à une vie économique pour nos
commerçants ou artisans toutes les
entreprises en reprenant nos
investissements parce que les
collectivités territoriales sont
importants dans cette reprise économique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]